here with more fox business anchor larry
kudlow is with us you know i wrote a
book in 2020 because i just thought the
moment call for it is the first book i
wrote in 10 years live free or die
chapter 4
socialism's history of failure
isn't the new green deal basically
socialism and doesn't socialism always
end the same way whatever name whatever
manifestation
unfulfilled promises more poverty and
then you measure how much freedom you
gave up in the name of false security
you know sean by the way i read the book
just let the record show i actually read
the book thank you
now look at they just put out their new
projections this is the white house omb
projections so over the next ten years
they estimate the american economy will
grow at slightly less than two percent a
year which is a pathetic low number and
my point is if all this big government
socialism and green new deal and higher
taxes and regulations and you know
bailing out wealthy college kids if all
this stuff is so good then why don't
their own estimates show that they can
build a much stronger larger more
prosperous greater opportunity economy i
mean it's like show me the beef okay you
think you're so hot then show me the
results and they can't do that it's an
absolute failure so they marked down
their growth numbers and they marked up
their inflation numbers which is what
the whole world's been telling them for
months and months and months and now
they're just trying to fib about it and
let me make another point here this
student loan stuff you know sean the
education department which has become a
kind of hotbed of critical race theory
and sex and gender ids they don't know
anything about loans this was obama's
brainchild to stop banks and private
lenders from making student loans where
they do know something about credit risk
and give it over to the education
department that's where the 1.6 trillion
student loans have gone they should stop
this take it away from the edgeocrats
put it back into the private sector and
let people pay a market rate and if that
happened sean these outrageous college
tuition increases would probably simmer
down pretty fast
well isn't it amazing that let's say
somebody goes into the trades doesn't go
to college why should they be forced to
pay for somebody else's loan or what
about all of us that i did take out a
student loan and i did work full-time
jobs when i went to college you know why
do i have to pay for somebody else's
loan when i worked hard to pay my own
way to get through college to the point
that i got to i didn't finish why why
should i have to pay well the short
answer is you shouldn't i mean look this
is election vote buying that's all this
really is trying to bolster up i guess
biden's saggy numbers democratic party
sagging numbers on young people but it's
not going to work because there's a big
resentment people know basically what
you just said i mean look going way back
i had to take out some loans for
graduate school but i did pay them back
most folks honor their obligations this
idea of student loan debt default is
relatively new interest rates have been
in rock bottom for the last few years
still didn't
cover the loans properly so let's stop
this larry kudlow always great to have
you thank you my friend hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else